do you remember the last time you were
in Tucson no what happened do you
remember it I do cuz I have a voicemail
from when you called me in Tucson what
what was it desperate okay so he had
just um checked into um a rehab oh yeah
yeah yeah I remember like a year ago
they have like a lot of rehab voicemail
what can I play your voicemail when you
called me from the payone yeah you have
it I have it oh yeah I want to hear yeah
yeah yeah yeah I don't know you have it
Tucson is a place where you find
yourself or you destroy yourself D it's
neither one of those play you know so I
for people listening I um you know the
last time I got was using I was in a
desperate Dire Straits and I was in
this rehab Mill and they took away my
phone and everything and they were
giving me like you know like those
psychi like I would go to wait in this
line and they would give me like 15
pills really they would make you eat it
and they'd check your mouth to make sure
you were yeah and I swallowed it and I
just remember like people just I was
walking around like a zombie you know
what I mean it was [__] terrible with
like 50 [__] people but why was that
place even recommended to us to be
because they had changed ownership oh it
used to be good it used to be like oh we
only have 10 people here and they're all
celebrities yeah and all of a sudden
another gigantic company devoured them
it just became a mil and they're like as
many people anybody here we go yes uh oh
you've never heard this Bobby no I swear
to God no I don't remember even calling
her okay hang hang on hang on hang on
hang on hang on okay you sound so
serious hey sweetie um I had dinner the
food is
terrible it's terrible oh my god
um it's like Oz like there's fights
breaking out it's like people stalking
me it's
terrible um I know if someone was asleep
tonight but um quiet because there's
like 52 men talking on phones around me
um I feel like I'm in prison I'm in
one I love you I'm going to try to sleep
tonight but I'm don't think it's going
to happen bye
oh oh so sad of remember like some of it
now no that uh that feels like my
college experience yeah ban tuon was
[__] wild it's wild I um you get laid
not for the first couple years I let me
look at your face it's good very good
it's a good face your voice must have
gotten you a long comic well I started
working at a radio station and that's
when I I got hired at KF in Tucson and
that's I older women started having sex
with me when I was
girls at UA would not [__] with me cuz I
wasn't like a frat guy I didn't have a
lot of confidence I was like super
insecure uh you know that's what leads
you to stand up yeah you're probably
skinny too huh yeah I was I was like I
was really gangly yeah and then older
women were just like
hey hey kind of weird broken boy you see
old or how old like I was 20 21 and like
35 yeah that makes sense 36y old women
it was the first time I ever had sex and
a woman was like slow
down legitimately she was like SL
slow go into your slow for but I really
cuz I was just like you know I was like
20 so I just Jackhammer wow and then
they they were like slow down buddy what
a great note it was the best Note I've
ever gotten sexually was slow down
because I didn't realize what I was
doing it made me be in it more made me
realize you know you got to work your
way up to the speed you can't start with
speed and that's what I was I was just
like drop in
like that lady was like yeah you got to
chill guy yeah yeah yeah but uh you got
a slow forat D yeah and it was it was
because of the radio station in the
comedy club I started getting Glade like
wow because I you I would just strike
out the second they smelled any
insecurity on me yeah they were like
okay but did you care about rejection or
no yeah yeah it hurt it always it's
funny as you get older cuz I'm single
now I'm 52 almost yeah it doesn't
doesn't really hurt you know mean bad
who gives a [__] you don't give a [__]
but as a 20-year-old it's so you know
you the rejection is so painful yeah
it's apocalyptic it's apocalyptic you're
like [__] this is it and I remember this
girl that I had such a big crush on
sophomore year she had an Ohio accent
one of those like d how are
you and I was in love with her and I was
foolishly like I didn't realize she had
a boyfriend like she said like oh I'm
seeing a guy back home but I was like
yeah but he's back in Ohio at UA
whatever and so we'd like hang out and
then she would like want to do school
projects with me and stuff so I was like
oh was working and then like on one of
our last days of class I was like Hey so
like before winter break do you want to
go get dinner with me and in front like
in in like the quad area where
everyone's filing out of the building
she just goes Dan I have a
boyfriend
like really yeah dude I was like I I
just remember I remember feeling like
Mortal Kombat like like someone punched
my body and ripped my heart out I was
like oh yeah cool you guys are going to
great together it was but it was
Rejection it was rejection at but in
retrospect it's probably somebody that
you wouldn't hook up with now no man it
all like uh the woman I'm marrying i'
I've never been in a relationship that's
better that I'm happier that I'm like
that I'm like I I jokingly tell her cuz
it's been 10 years since I've drank
alcohol but I joke wait wait wait you're
sober guy I smoke weed okay that's what
I brought from that's what I was so
early why why why why though why why'd
you quit drinking I had a problem I had
a real big problem um but I I jokingly
tell her I'm like if I lose you the
sauce is coming back like I'm going to
start drinking again so it was a problem
how long you've been dating this woman
uh four years all right so we've been
engaged almost a year how how did you
meet uh on opian gym wow yeah her name
she's Katie Katie Nolan is my fiance
from ESPN yeah yeah formerly of ESPN in
Fox she's the best thing in the world
world you know without Opie and
Anthony I wouldn't be the podcaster I am
now really it taught me everything going
on op and Anthony yeah because the first
time I went in there I was so scared oh
my God I remember that the first time
you're on op and Anthony and you're like
sitting there you're like am I going to
get [__] ripped apart they would rip
apart guys rip you